[Music]
let's check out another reporter what do
you say Marsh
your walrus is in uh so this is this is
um you guys know that one of my
obsessions is
you know reporters and correspondents
that are just off the rails or like just
insane I always keep an eye out for them
for the show this was very early in the
morning when the storm was blowing
through and it was already passed and it
was this is I think Tampa yeah it's
Tampa because the guy's staying across
from Raymond James
this is like a minute ago the reason I
left in these two talking is because the
build up you need the build up because
that being very stoic and like wow we
really dodged a bullet today the
citizens of tampers there and then they
go to this guy who you can tell right
after the storm blew through just
started getting litty with the boys at
his hotel and by the way don't blame him
I don't blame it by the time they throw
to him he's [ __ ] gone so many people
are in Polk County right now without
power 182 000 customers don't have power
in Polk County and again the worst of
this storm is passing through Polk
County so we anticipate those numbers to
increase as those winds continue to
pound that area but you know Greg D
we'll check in with him a little while
to find out how much longer you know
Polk County can expecting Polk County
respect to experiences this storm sounds
you know this this wind right exactly
you know but it's kind of hard to
believe before we get to drunk report
are we going to talk about Adderall
addict reporter first oh I mean I mean
hey least Adderall guy is being a pro
you know I'd rather my news anchors on
Adderall while we're doing 24-hour
[ __ ] hurricane coverage not the drunk
guy at the [ __ ] the [ __ ] the
Holiday Inn across from Raymond James
I'm just glad that Nick Papa Giorgio
from Vegas vacation has a job now so
that's pretty cool Nick Papa Georgio
yeah what a [ __ ] movie I know but a good
reference good reference [ __ ] movie
vacation
our weather Department said hard to
believe I'll tell you what why don't you
just give me half the money I take you
off back and kick you in the nuts that
was [ __ ] fun one of the funniest
things there's some great lines it's a
shitty movie but there's some great
lines the best line in that entire movie
is right at the beginning of a [ __ ]
Chevy Chase says something about like
you [ __ ] I hardly recognize you guys
anymore and then he kind of eyeballs
them
[ __ ] they change the Kids actors in
every movie
the 12 hours ago we had a category near
Category 5 storm
making landfall in our state what is
what will easily be one of the top five
storms that it ever hit the State of
Florida and bear five Hurricane Andrew
I'll [ __ ] kill you
[ __ ] guys
Hurricane Katrina
have you [ __ ] seen have you seen the
meme in his comment sections where
they're like he talks like that because
he has a collapsed lung
number three Disney's The Hurricane oh
[ __ ]
okay sorry
Florida and now is it disintegrates and
deteriorates we're left to pick up the
pieces and see uh what exactly it is
left behind Greg D says at five o'clock
he expects the National Hurricane Center
to downgrade this to a tropical storm
yes and so yesterday we were telling you
I was downgraded when it was over us
Marsh as a matter of fact I think that's
when the downgrade yeah it was right
when it was already cut to me yeah yeah
it was one when it got to me and it was
already [ __ ] disintegrating slow it
was moving and as it was sitting and
spinning and really glad you're causing
all these problems I'm really glad you
mentioned this because I wasn't talking
so five minutes
so [ __ ] hopped up like everybody tell
right I don't blame them because
the sober one let me guess this was
probably you recording this for like a
two in the morning or something right
something because oh no this was like
three four in the morning okay so that's
my point yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
these reporters haven't slept at this
point for a while that's what I mean but
that's why I wait wait for the Christian
oh I can't wait I already love this clip
and you haven't even gotten to the good
part yet way to Florida and now once it
came on land moving out of the way not
moving as quickly as we would like but
still moving out of the way but being
quickly downgraded I mean quickly
tearing apart and it will be downgraded
hopefully at five o'clock to a tropical
storm faster than a crawl and speaking
specifically about our region our
viewing area and outside our studios
here in Tampa uh it's great news we are
looking at um insane amounts of rainfall
the track it must suck to be a local
reporter now because like you're this
guy you're on the news every day and the
only people that recognize your old
ladies that still watch local news yeah
old people yeah
James you're James from Channel
it's never any [ __ ] hot 26 year olds
that this storm took up through
Southwest Florida and and you guys
should have been a YouTuber yeah the
center of our state but as far as we're
concerned here around the bay
whereas
some [ __ ] hot Florida MILFs probably
occasionally that's true that's a good
point yeah
so we have a little moment of gratitude
I think they go to the guy now here we
go God is on Bayshore Boulevard she's
been showing us just the incredible
image the bay the water out of the bay I
mean there's no there's no water there
but again we're waiting for high tide at
4 30. so in about 35 minutes and we're
expecting of course that water to come
back in Greg D's going to walk us
through what to expect but they're not
expecting you know it's not it's not as
big of a concern as it was yesterday at
this time Dennis at one point saying I
don't even want to say concern that's
too strong of a word we're looking at
all right we'll be right we're here with
you for that as well I think we're going
to go to Sean daily
he's like Santa Claus he's up on the
rooftop but don't get him started I know
we need a little bit of levity this
morning hey Sean let's just start with
this uh you're overlooking uh Raymond
James Stadium there we don't have any
official word here uh Minnesota
your best guess
that game's going to be played there
Sunday night I mean listen you know if
it is a structural thing with Raymond
James Stadium the game will be played
here however
Florida has suffered a real tragedy if
they would move it for that I don't know
if Jacksonville I mean there are other
football teams I imagine that it
probably will be played and that the NFL
would do something
um as far as honoring victims or or
helping with this and it's dude if he's
a sports guy if I move I obviously
Sports guy to just go get drunk across a
Raymond James Stadium and get good
hurricane footage but it was a dud so
now he's just lit
believe something like that you know and
you know uh James Tully and I we we
battle in fantasy football football is a
diversion right it is a diversion it's
something to take our mind off of things
when things get rough so what else is
just diversion Jack is Jack Daniels a
diversion what's the Divergence are you
let me let me guess you're drinking out
of those little plastic cups they give
you in the hotels is that what's
happening this is the [ __ ] this is
bro the way he's like rambling is the
way you ramble at a bar
Electric football you know it's like a
diversion for problems you know like
he's just making small talk oh my God I
meant God I missed Joe Namath this guy
was all set up all day and all evening
to get some of the best footage ever and
it was a dud and then they just hung out
and drank all night and then they were
like all right well we still need to
throw to you at like four in the morning
and he's like what I don't blame him by
the way because you what would you do
what do you mean there's things that
died I thought we were going home
they're like nah man we're gonna milk
this for a couple more hours I'm
surprised he's not smoking a cigarette
while doing this to be honest he's the
best yeah I love this guy Sean Daly
rules so maybe it would be good for that
I don't know maybe we go for
football
there to have the game here you know I
mean
you know it just it takes our mind off
things now one thing I do want to
mention about the weather here in Tampa
no more rain it is pretty Gusty you can
see my luscious locks maybe blowing in
the breeze
hammered
he has the energy not hammered but he's
drunk he's actually fun drunk he he has
the energy of a recently divorced guy in
his mid-40s hitting on a Hooters
waitress
yes that's that's that exact Vibe this
guy a golf shirt yes that 26 year old
yeah
he walks up and trying to fight out of
touch sorry you're a fan of fetty WAP
yeah just completely just just dumbest I
love the fetty WAP I love the are you a
fan of the fetty WAP
thing that people will be surprised by
hey you want to go smoke some grass in
my Jesus
and she's like she's like no man I have
a vape here what are you doing he's the
kind of guy that pronounces it Porsche
yeah Porsche took some grass in my
Porsche
and it's the one with the big spoiler in
the back the old one
oh yeah just just to 944. yeah 9 44 yeah
and then he invites him out there and
she goes just move my kids art out of
the seat just throw it in the back it's
fine you could
it's fine you can throw that out I want
to smoke some reefer in my vet that's my
vet oh he calls it a vet not a Corvette
he calls it a vet yeah he's the guy that
has the Corvette jacket over his golf
shirt it's a Z06 it's from 1994 though
it's not that impressive
now I got an older one because then I
could have the antique uh uh car
insurance
[Laughter]
for that thing antique plates
I love the background we've given this
guy because looking at him he's Tampa
he's the sports guy we're probably
pretty close probably probably close to
the Target if not on target oh we're
gonna clip this butt if you see this let
us know in the comments okay I'll make
sure you see it I'll send it to you on
Twitter but when they wait by the way I
want to point out I like him because oh
I love this guy this is what any one of
us would do if we were this guy it's
like well the story [ __ ] sucks you
just want to drink I guess yes this is
dude I would be hanging out with this
guy like this rules yeah let's get some
beers Man by the way they're paying for
it we can empty the mini bar the
station's paying for it emptying the
mini bar let's go pay for it anyway
we're gonna empty the mini bar I'm gonna
roll up a couple yeah let's go
hey you want a 16 bag of M M's yeah
and then all of a sudden they're just
like all right Sean you're gonna be uh
we're gonna throw you in about 45
minutes
and you're like well you might as well
get more lit on me you want to add a
roll you think he's doing the thing in
the mirror right before he goes live
where he's like he's just [ __ ] He's
smacking himself come on come on water
he's throwing water come on come on come
on come on come on
you interviewed Tom Brady God damn it
you could do this
laughs
I don't know why season Tom Brady got
drunk when he first came to town this
guy's bringing me so much joy just
everything about him is so Tampa he's
the best I had to dude immediately this
is literally unlisted on the night I
know live Channel I had to grab this
Last Night Live this is amazing it's too
good
up this morning and super smart people
like Greg D can probably tell us why
this is surprised so wise
it's rather chilly out all of a sudden
and there is a real chill in the wind
and I'm kind of curious hey that's
because you left that's because you left
the AC on full blast in the hotel
exactly you're not wearing pants and
you're not wearing pants
you're only working sucks
your balls and your [ __ ] are exposed
right across from Raymond James
I do that wow that's very chilly out now
yes stupid that's what happens when a
storm comes out are you new to Florida
that's why that is maybe Greg D can tell
us something about it he's definitely
not new to Whiskey I'll tell you that
because because immediately after the
storms the uh barometric pressure goes
up barometric pressure goes up and the
[ __ ] temperature goes down and the
humidity goes down so it's cooler this
guy's [ __ ] this guy [ __ ] simple
science Sean
at the hurricane moving off but I think
people are going to wake up it feels
like football weather anyway I hope my
pontoon boat's okay it was parked in
Marina Fort Myers so hope is fine this
entire thing has been about football
he's totally their Sports guy yeah
it feels like it's like the November or
December so that's kind of interesting
too the ghost
but again it's probably going to be a
beautiful day here in Tampa which like
you were saying James Tully is just wow
he's hammered he's doing he's doing the
yeah he's doing the yeah this if if if
you were If This Were a traffic stop he
would be definitely getting a [ __ ]
even be getting a [ __ ] test actually
if it's in Tampa be like you're the
sports guy right him I just get home
safely are you Sean Daly all right man
Sean come on bro just get home safe dude
come on man
I'm book look
the Bucks have been winning since you've
been there so like I'm gonna let you go
but if they lose [ __ ] ticket bro
blowing after the stress and everything
we just went through right but I mean
here what did you go through besides the
mini bar Sean we are in Tampa pretty
good day yeah 100 Years of luck when it
comes to hurricanes so very very blessed
like I said earlier give back when when
when you are blessed like this give back
to others and help others going through
a tough time but yeah guys back to you
on that we got lucky all right Sean Daly
live for us right outside our studio
conditions look just fine out there and
we were telling you yesterday about this
trouble that's pretty much it I just
and talk about icing out Sean Daly
yeah I don't think James likes Shaw
chamber no he's like don't bring me to
your fantasy football [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
not your friend okay I'm your colleague